il est le candidat de la république en
marche sur la 11e circonscription des
yvelines pierre luce a été désigné ce
mercredi 29 juillet par le bureau
national du parti de la majorité
présidentielle
il tentera de prendre la suite de nadia
et lors de ces législatives partielles
l'ancien député lrm a démissionné en
juillet dernier suite à sa nomination
comme ministre délégué en charge de la
ville je suis très honoré d'avoir été
investi par alpiq en marche
il me tient à coeur d'être le candidat
de la proximité avec les habitants je
veux connais bien à sa conception je
connais les problématiques des citoyens
qui vivent ici quotidiennement et nous
j'espère pouvoir les convaincre qu'avec
un député de la majorité présidentielle
pourrait continuer à porter leur message
à porter leurs voix à l'assemblée
nationale cet ingénieur informatique de
32 ans est entrée en politique en 2016
dès le lancement du mouvement en marche
le militant également créé le premier
comité local lrm à saint quentin en
yvelines
il est devenu délégué départemental
depuis janvier 2019
je suis un homme de terrain je suis un
homme politique de contact j'apprécie le
contact avec les habitants
je leur parle rem le dialogue et c'est
pour moi quelque chose d'essentiel
les deux fondateurs dans mon engagement
politique cette capacité est proche du
terrain le mord pas y aura face à lui
philippe benassaya mer les républicains
de bois d'arcy aucun mouvement de gauche
n'a pour l'instant communiqué sur un
possible candidat
le scrutin devrait se tenir fin
septembre